we want to give a big thank you this
morning to our fabulous channel eight
viewers john
that's right eight news now was
celebrating our parent company next star
is founders day yesterday and all day
long
you all stopped by our studio to drop
off clothing
food water some local celebrities look
chance was there as well
former golden knight derek england and
his family stopped by
all of this to benefit the salvation
army and three three square food bank
and they say your donations are going to
make a big impact
it takes a great deal to be able to to
create food security when
you know maybe as much as 15 of our
population is food insecure
so it's a very very large effort and so
las vegas always continues to rise
indication
once again a big thank you to everybody
who came out to join us it was so great
alex to meet our viewers and
uh chat with them about it and what they
were doing up so early and how they
you know how they talk about how they
watch us while they're brushing their
teeth and buttering
their bread and toasting or whatever so
that was fantastic
yes it was really fun thank you to
everyone who came by yesterday it's
great